it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive low prices during Black
History Month we'll share some products
from black owned businesses to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com good housekeeping's
executive textiles director Lexi Sachs
is with us right now good morning Alexa
good morning I'm great how are you all
right so what do we got here let's jump
right into it yes we've got a lot of
favorites here today these have all been
tested by us at the Good Housekeeping
Institute so we're so excited so we're
going to start with the calming heat
background I'm going to give it to you
to try on all right for my paperwork
down there you go okay so normally
heating pads can fall off you this is
adjustable it goes around your waist and
it stays put no matter where you are
pretty awesome exactly you have the heat
you have the vibrations and you have
that Lumber support so it's great if
you're sitting in a chair yeah because
you got the back support right yeah
anyone who sits at a desk this is
perfect for so you have the remote here
there are three levels for each of them
for the intensity the vibrations the
lumbar support and the heat so fully
customizable so and if you stand it up
all day Tony has a stand-up desk so
exactly it helps with that as well right
no matter where you are it's
transportable you can use it anywhere
which is great okay what's the price on
this this is 35 off today on
cbsdeals.com it's 51.99 that's a
fraction of the cost of massage and you
can keep using it over and over again
all right all right what do we got next
okay over here is drop stop this is one
of the best selling products that was
seen on Shark Tank and what it does is
this slips right over your seatbelt
latch it blocks that gap between your
car seat and the center console so it
stops things from dropping through so if
you're driving and you drop something
like your phone or food your instinct is
to reach down and grab it and taking
your eyes off the road for a split
second can really have you know
devastating effects it's really
dangerous so this prevents that it makes
it much safer and I will say as a mom
I'm often in that passenger seat dealing
with my kids in the back seat I'm
passing back food I'm passing back toys
I can't tell you the amount of time I
have spent digging through that bottom
seat to find what I've dropped so it's a
total Game Changer from convenience on
top about with them gnarled fingers
trying to exactly it's painful price on
this this is the best deal we've had so
this is 15.99 for two a great price that
is a good deal all right what about this
all right here for the pets this is link
my pet okay this is like having
smartphone capabilities here but I see
you are loving it right now it goes
right on their collar it's a wearable
it's lightweight you can wear it on
their collar and it tracks a lot of
different things it tracks their
location it tracks their activity you
can track health information so the
biggest thing I like to call it for this
is the fact that pets have been going
missing so much in my hometown I'm
constantly seeing alerts and you don't
realize how badly you need it until it's
too late unfortunately so it gives you a
lot of peace of mind it does track
activity it all goes right to your
smartphone everything's done through the
app so if you're at work you can see
what your dog's doing if they're being
active or not it has built-in training
capabilities there is a pleasant noise
it's kind of like that clicking sound
when you're training patch there's
vibrations for stopping that unwanted
Behavior so there's a lot that it does
you also get access to a concierge 24 7
through this that's convenient great so
what's the price on this all right 40
off cbsdeals.com it is 89.99 so under
100 and it comes with a lot all right so
what do we have here okay last thing we
have here this is from Rock Innovations
this is the brand that we're so excited
to highlight for Black History Month it
was started by Raquel Graham down so she
had it had this idea of making these
problem-solving products that just make
your life easier so we're so excited to
showcase the headlights here so we have
beanies and we have headbands with these
built-in LED lights I'm going to give
you one to model because these are so
stretchy and soft and really comfortable
they're one size oh that's comfy yeah so
as a hat alone it's great but then you
get the added benefit of this LED light
it's rechargeable you can take it out
and recharge it three different
intensities so I will say it's great for
convenience if you can be hands-free
this is um 17.50 a great price for a
beanie alone then you get that added
convenient safety all of that you're the
best I appreciate you scan the QR code
get the deals we'll see you tomorrow